welcome to the michaela peterson podcast
episode number 73 i had the absolute
pleasure of interviewing michael francis
and sunil
tulciani michael francis is a former mob
boss that has an
insane story about literally running the
mob
in new york in the 1970s making
billions and then going to jail and
ultimately turning his life around
he's now a successful motivational
speaker and entrepreneur that teaches
people negotiating techniques
and how to communicate and be successful
and he's very successful
sunil tolciani is a former cop turned
real estate mogul
best-selling author speaker and founder
of private investment club
i found this conversation super
interesting and was going to make it
into an opposing views episode
with a mob boss and a cop but they ended
up agreeing on a lot
it was interesting to see both sides of
the story though please remember to hit
subscribe if you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by raw
optics raw optics is where i get my blue
light blocking glasses
i don't have glasses to show you because
i forgot them in toronto
actually i'll put my profile picture up
here with my favorite glasses they have
i forgot them which i've been seriously
lamenting because recording videos at
night with these
blinding lights kills your circadian
rhythm and the blue light blocking
glasses really help with that
if you have trouble sleeping or you work
late or you want to just calm your brain
down before going to bed
wearing their red glasses in the evening
can really help if you work under
fluorescent lights or you're in airports
or something similar to that
they have daytime blue light blocking
glasses too they're my favorite brand
super cute glasses or sexy if you're a
dude and feel threatened when i describe
glasses as cute
code m a p for ten percent off
at raw optics r a optics dot com
and it's linked in the description i
hope you enjoy this episode
[Music]
so neil and michael welcome to my
podcast
thank you michaela thanks for having us
this is going to be exciting i
always start my podcast off the same way
which is for my audience if they don't
know who you are
so would you we can start with michael
would you give a brief background about
who you are and what it is that you do
sure i was born in brooklyn new york
um my dad sonny francis was the
underboss of the columbo family one of
the five new york
was in austria mafia families uh back in
the 60s
and so i grew up in that environment my
dad was a very high profile figure kind
of like the john gotti of his day
always under investigation major target
of law enforcement so i grew up
you know in that kind of an atmosphere i
love my dad very much he was my hero
in life and um in the 60s he got in some
serious trouble he was indicted several
times three times in the state of new
york
uh was acquitted in three different
trials but then in 1966 he was indicted
in federal court
for masterminding a nationwide string of
bank robberies he was convicted
sentenced to 50 years in prison and uh
after losing all his appeals in 1970 he
went off to do his time
i was a pre-med student hofstra
university at that time i was an athlete
you know in school and
he's going to be a doctor when my dad
went in joe colombo the boss of our
family kind of took me under his wing i
obviously knew them well
started to meet a lot of my dad's
friends mike what are you doing going to
school
if you don't help your father out he's
going to die in prison long story short
my dad and i met in the visiting room in
leavenworth penitentiary
and i told him i wasn't going to school
because he had always professed his
innocence to me he said mike i'm not a
bank robber i was framed in this case
i believed him and i felt that i had to
do whatever i had to do to basically
um you know salvage a death sentence
because he was 50 when he went in at 50
on top of that
i figured he'd never come out of prison
alive so during that meeting my dad
uh said to me if you're going to be on
the street i want you on the street the
right way
and he proposed me for membership into
the columbo family
at that point i became a recruit i was
21 years old for the next two and a half
years
you know i had to do what i had to do to
prove myself and i was
admitted into the family on halloween
night here in america
1975 october 31 1975
came into the life as a soldier and
i knew how to use that life to benefit
me in business went on to make a
significant amount of money for the
family
1980 i was appointed the position of
copper regime or captain
and you know was in that position for
quite some time
i became a major target of law
enforcement i was indicted
actually seven different times i had two
federal racketeering cases one brought
on by rudy giuliani
a case in which i was acquitted in or i
wouldn't be sitting here today
the amount of time they were given out i
had five other cases
that were state cases i eventually took
a plea i had devised a scheme to defraud
the government out of tax on every
gallon of gasoline
it was a major operation that i ran for
close to eight years
i eventually took a plea in that case i
got a 10-year prison sentence 15 million
dollars in restitution went off to do my
time but prior to that
i met a young woman who's now my wife of
35 years
and i married her just before i went in
and
as a result of my being with her i
decided to try to walk away from that
life
and without getting into all the detail
it's something i was able to do
successfully and you know when i got out
of prison
um you know i didn't plan it but uh i
embarked on a
speaking career i've been sharing my
testimony as a christian
and speaking at you know all different
forms throughout the world
and i've written a number of books i'm
doing television shows
i'm on youtube now and you know life has
been uh
very blessed for me so that's kind of
the story up to now
that is that is a that's an insane story
sounds like you have quite a wife uh
she's the reason why i'm here and able
to talk to you if it wasn't for her i'd
either be dead or in prison for the rest
of my life because
you know meeting her and not wanting to
put her through
what my family went through as a result
of my dad
being in that life and being in prison
she was my motivation to walk away
and uh that wasn't easy you know a lot
of struggles a lot of challenges you're
not allowed to walk away from that life
but somehow we managed to do that and
here i am today so very blessed
okay sunil you're here as well
thank you very much you have experience
as a police officer so i thought
having two different perspectives on a
whole bunch of different aspects of life
from someone who was involved
in crime and a police officer i thought
that
would be interesting so can you give a
brief background about
who you are and what it is that you do
or used to do
um so i i was born in india came to
toronto
with my family with mom and dad in 1981
and i was a really really bad student i
mean i just didn't like school i didn't
like any of the stuff i i you know and
then one day my uncle comes to me and
says you should be a police officer
i was the age of 15 and uh from that on
i knew that there's only one thing that
i could do
that i wanted to do was be a police
officer and from that age
everything that i did meaning i if i had
to take an education course
if it didn't take me to that then i just
didn't take it so i barely passed high
school
and in in um and and when i was 21 years
old
i became a police officer and um
i went from being a uniform officer to
becoming a police detective then i
became a platoon
uh police negotiator and finally i
became a platoon commander
and it was about 15 years of policing
when my wife comes to me and says we're
going to have a divorce
and we have two kids and my daughter at
that time was
approximately let's say
four years old and my son was about 10
years old and i didn't want to lose them
so i used to tell people that
my my family is the most important part
like policing is secondary families
you know first but the truth was that i
was
if a call came from the police
department said you know there's some
overtime or you can go out and do this
i would just forget any promises that i
would made with the family
and i would just go out and do the work
and my dialogue was very simple
i'm doing it for you i'm doing it for
you so so my wife came to me and said
we're gonna have a divorce
in 15 years later at policing she says
we're gonna have divorce and all that
stuff
so it was time for me to prove what i
said was real because the reality is
i was saying one thing family is
important but
doing things that prove that family
wasn't important to me as much
so i left that police force
profession and i opened up this
newspaper from this guy named robert
allen
and he says buy properties no money down
and i i spent five thousand dollars
i went to his three-day course and that
first year alone i ended up buying and
selling 77 properties
and i was a shy guy a lack of
self-confidence
you know people told me you're not going
to amount to anything you're too dark
too skinny to this you can't speak
english and all that kind of stuff
so for me if you told me to get up on
stage
for 30 seconds in front of 20 people
i would just melt to the ground i was it
was not something that i would do
so long story short we celebrated our
28th marriage anniversary
uh two couple of months ago my son who's
26 years old who just turned 26
years old he's in this business with me
and my my daughter who's 20 years old
she's with us so the family is together
and now i have this largest elite real
estate club
in north america called private
investment club
and and it's been um you know i've done
really well financially
but most important part to me is that
we're still together
like the whole family's together we're
still doing well
and we have great relationships and
that's the important
so when i say wealthy to me the the
media calls me the wealthy cop
and to me of course they called me
wealthy because of money
but for me it's money time
relationship and my mom and dad and
all that's the wealth that i have
accumulated
that's very important to me
okay now for the questions i'm gonna
throw a bunch of questions that are
somewhat similar uh at both of you but
but in kind of opposite ways
so
michael how
often did you end up coming across
bad cops in your line of work how like
how frequent was that
well for us you know the bad cops were
good cops because
you know to make deals with them and you
know i'll tell you how it was in new
york
you know since new york is kind of the
the real base of operation for cousin
austria in america
we had five families we had 750 guys at
that time that were actually
made members guys that took the oath we
had a lot of associates
but because we had such big numbers many
of us had relatives that were
you know policemen you know detectives
we had neighbors
with that so you know we had
relationships in that regard
and you know a lot of the cops they
didn't bother us for the things that we
did it was more the feds that were on
top of us so we had
you know we had gambling operations
where we would you know pay off the cops
a little bit just to leave us alone
every once in a while we would throw
them a bus
so they needed one uh but it was quite
common
i mean there was one you know precinct
in new york where in brooklyn i should
say i'm sorry
when uh you know two o'clock in the
morning i was able to go in there and
look through files and see if there was
anything
that was of interest to me so it was
quite frequent
um because again because of the numbers
because of the relationships that we had
and because i guess
you know the attitude uh that the cops
had with us
you know we weren't got we weren't the
guys out there committing the street
crimes we weren't shooting people up and
robbing stores and doing all of that we
were
in a little bit of a different level so
we were able to make those relationships
okay that makes sense is being a cop
like being part of a gang
is being cough like being part of gang i
i would say
that uh there are some components to
that
i would say the friendships
the deep relationships uh the being able
to trust each other
[Music]
was there might be
that component to that uh from from that
point of view
um uh but of course uh we're on the
opposite side of the coin i guess when i
was a police officer
that's what i i would consider myself to
be a really good cop i mean i was really
i i mean we're in canada of course and
in toronto where i was a cop i mean uh
even when i was detective and doing all
this stuff
i would say 90 of the people that i knew
the officers i knew maybe 95
of the officers i knew they were amazing
people they wanted to
go out they wanted to save the world
they wanted to
you know catch the bad guys basically at
the end of the day that's what it was
and and for me uh the important part
that i missed today from that life
sometimes is what i just said is the
friendships with these officers that was
like okay i'll take a bullet for you but
that doesn't happen
generally speaking in the business world
sometime
very very rarely does it happen
is that how it felt like for you did you
picture yourself
as one of the good guys
well um look we had a very idealistic
view
of who we were back then you know when
we took that oath
it was something special because it was
uh this brotherhood that we were
entering into you know i got your back
you got mine
united got made they told me mike
wherever you travel in the world
somebody will be there to have your back
don't ever worry about your wife your
daughter your sister
your mother you know nobody will ever
disrespect them
and you're part of a family a
brotherhood and yeah that's a very
powerful feeling i mean
you know i the night that i got made it
was exhilarating
to me you know i had an additional you
know blood bond with my father
and you know i think to a certain extent
that's true
um but you know like anything else you
know money and power
you know they corrupt and it corrupted
that life in many ways i saw a lot of
things happen that
uh that shouldn't have happened you know
people that got hurt suffered
consequences
for more political reasons um and uh
you know so this idealistic view that i
had of the life didn't last
you know when i walked away it wasn't
because i was mad at anybody or
or anything i walked away basically to
preserve my family but
uh it's not all what it's cracked up to
be and you know i don't know if you can
say that the same of the of the police
but um
you know it just isn't and and like i
said sad um but it isn't
how did you manage briefly how did you
manage to get out because what you hear
or i don't know the only place i've
learned about anything that has to do
with
mafia is from the a movie realistically
i haven't actually talked to anyone just
you now but
what i've seen in movies is you don't
get out you you
either die or you end up in jail um
and so how did you how did you manage it
i know that you went to jail and you did
your time but
how did you manage to get away without
anyone harboring resentments
well you're right mikhail you're not
allowed to to leave that life i mean i
i basically broke my oath you know
america i mean i speak about the life i
don't speak about it in terms of putting
people in trouble
but i do talk about the life and um you
know i think for me it was two reasons
number one one of the horrors of that
life
is that you know you make a mistake or
whatever political reason happens in
there and
and your best friend walks you into a
room and you don't walk out again
and um unfortunately in my 20 years in
that life
you know i've experienced that with
others and
um so what i said is this you know
people are very upset
with me i mean my father practically
disowned me when i walked away i mean
everybody thought i was going to start
testifying against people because
normally that's what happens you make a
deal with the government you start
informing you go into the witness
protection program
but that's not what i was about i didn't
want to do that i didn't want to hurt
anybody
i just wanted out so the boss of my
family you know carmine persico who
who passed away last year he was very
upset with me
contract on my life i mean i had the
whole thing i had some
you know severe struggles but here's
what what i did
fortunately i knew the life intimately
well i could never have stayed in new
york there was no way i would have made
it
i move out to california i changed my
own
entire lifestyle meaning that i didn't
create patterns in my life in case
people were looking at me
i didn't walk my dog every morning at
seven o'clock i didn't go to the same
restaurant every tuesday night i stayed
out of night clubs because i know their
bad place for me i know who hangs out
there
i'm fairly well known somebody makes a
call to new york i go into the parking
lot boom
i'm gone so i avoided all of that i was
very disciplined about it
and um you know the second reason for me
is you know i'm a strong person of faith
and i believe god had a different plan
and a purpose for my life that's become
very obvious to me
and uh you know what happened over a
period of time michaela
is i just outlasted everybody i mean
there was
you know i don't know if you know what
went on in the states especially in new
york but
when the government in the mid 80s um
you know created the racketeering law
and the bail reform act
and the sentencing reform act they were
putting people away left and right for
100 years 50 years 70 years
and uh you know guys had their own
things to worry about
and since i wasn't hurting anybody i
didn't testify against people
i wasn't you know causing anybody any
damage over a period of time they just
had to deal with their own troubles and
leave me alone and then everybody i
dealt with in that life
um is either dead or in prison for the
rest of their life everybody
so you know just very fortunate very
blessed
yeah that's a crazy story that's got to
be an incredibly stressful way to live
if you're trying to think of every
single opportunity where somebody could
get you and avoid all of those
how long did you have to do that for
well for quite some time you know when i
was out on parole it was it was tough
and uh
you know i would say there were years
because we what happened was
too uh you know that the fbi did me kind
of dirty they will put my name on the
witness list of trials that were coming
up
so even though i was sending word you
know back to my father i'm not going to
hurt anybody nobody believed me because
nobody just walks away and then my name
is coming up in all the discovery that
you know the defendants were getting so
but then trials kept coming and i never
appeared
so while that was happening i had a lot
of heat but then all of a sudden
i never appear i got violated on my
parole sent back to prison and people
saying hey this guy's not looking to
hurt anybody he just wants out
and then they kind of tend it to their
own business now don't get me wrong i
couldn't go back to new york and say hey
guys i'm moving back into the
neighborhood you know
i wouldn't have last too long but you
know i believe in god and god doesn't
tell you to be stupid you got to use
your head you know so
so um you know again just uh extremely
fortunate
and uh and very blessed that i've come
this far
wow yeah that's pretty wild story
um being a cop did you ever
have to uphold any laws that you were
uncomfortable with
uphold any laws that i was yeah or
arrest
people because of something they did
that you didn't necessarily think they
deserved to be arrested for
or anything like that yeah um i would
say
more so in courts than in
when i was arresting people um i mean
everybody knows that when
when it's black and white meaning we
know somebody killed or somebody did
this
or they didn't do it so that's easy for
for me to enforce
and it was easy for judges to you know
talk about
or or convict on but it's the it's a
gray area you got
you got you got two boys racing they're
20 years old
and they're on the highway and then one
uh somehow loses control but the other
one really
didn't really do anything but they were
both racing and then one rolls over the
person dies
and his best friend dies let's say
whatever in this case and i remember
this case going to the i had to do i
went there
and and basically my boss says this is
dangerous driving cause death
and that's uncomfortable thing for me to
do because
i've seen you know what happens on the
highways at night at two o'clock in the
morning once in a while and all that
stuff
and not saying that the people should do
that but in this case they were both
racing like no it knew each other and
one just lost control
and then died and this person gets can
charged with
dangerous driving cause death by me and
so
that's an example of something that is
sort of uh
when i'm looking that i was i was very
young at that time i was like maybe
24 25 in this case because i started
in a traffic unit went on to the crime
unit and all that stuff
in this case i'm laying the charge
because my boss says
this is what you have to do and and i
have to trust him and all that stuff so
i lay the charge
and then we do all the work and they go
to court and
and and throughout the uh in the court
you
if you're sitting there you have no idea
whether it's going to get convicted or
not in fact i was hoping
the judge is going to say okay look
listen you know
you were speeding we'll just you know
fine
you know all that kind of stuff and i
remember getting to know the family
i remember getting to know mom and dad
of this kid
and then two years later when this kid's
not even the same guy
two years later he's in the court and
and and and i'm expecting that he's
going to be
perhaps not get convicted and then at
the last
moment a judge goes uh okay two years in
jail
and and and dangerous driving caused
death and and that kind of criminal
record
and all that kind of stuff and then the
entire family crying and all that stuff
going home to that is is you know
sometimes
there are other examples that are more
severe but this was
i remember when i was very young and
like you know this could have happened
to anybody
like you know it's not that they cut
each other off or they you know they hit
each other and ran away and all that
kind of
basically one lost control they
shouldn't have been racing
and i've seen in other situations where
they're racing and they get a ticket
they just basically get a ticket so
there might there are times like that
and there's sometimes
you know um violence that occurs between
you know son and mother or
son and father for example where the son
pushes him and then father pushes back
and
and then father gets charged with abuse
uh so one is we already know that
there's an abuse it's it's it's
you know that should be convicted you
know they father comes on it's abusive
all the time and
and they shouldn't had no reason to do
it the other one is
the son pushes him and he's 17 years old
or something like that he's under 18
so he's not an adult and the father
pushes them back
and and and then police comes and then
we're told that you got to arrest
the father because he's he's abusing and
then the son basically says
yeah this happened this has happened in
the past and all that kind of
so it goes to trial and the truth really
doesn't
the past this stuff doesn't really come
out but based on that the father is now
being put away
to jail for doing that
push basically all that kind of stuff so
those are
those were uh uncomfortable things for
me because it was the gray area where
i wasn't in charge of that anymore and
then when i became the sergeant and when
i wanted kenpo to commander and all that
now i can tell my guys to make that
decision
okay well this is different and all that
stuff and
to me being in the position to be able
to make that decision
wasn't became important to me because i
did not want to see
regular people go to jail for
something that they couldn't do for
example it's very simple
just look at the drinking and driving i
would have
um immigrants who did not speak
the language the english language as
much and the police officer would stop
him and say okay
blow into this machine just you know
belong to the machine
and it's not like you just blow it
there's there's a certain amount of
breath that you need to provide and if
the person doesn't
uh understand it some officers
uh would just say okay refusal and
refusal is same
as being charged as drinking and driving
and so when i became in charge of that
situation i said no listen
we're gonna figure out that we're not
really charging and convicting people
for drinking and driving maybe because
some of them were
clearly they only had a beer like
clearly you can tell
okay that's complicated um that brings
me my next question but i'll start with
michael
okay um is there a type of person or a
type of personality that ends up
being drawn to something like the mafia
are there similarities between people in
there are there some people that are
i don't know shyer or quieter that say
no and some people
are more outgoing that say yes or some
sort of pattern
well you know i think most of the guys
that
were in that life kind of aspired to be
part of that life
you know for a long time they grew up in
the neighborhood they grew up around
these kind of guys
and they were attracted to the life you
know hey it's
what people think it's easy money it's
power it's prestige you get the women
you know the whole bit
and i think most people have that kind
of um
you know feeling that's why they want to
be involved and obviously
you know they're okay to cross the line
into criminal activity
you know um in my case you know i did it
really to help my dad
out it's not what i aspired to be all my
life as a matter of fact my father
didn't want me involved in that life
initially wanted me to
have a career be a doctor be a
professional but
obviously i had to have it in me um and
i had to
be able to cross the line i had to be
able to have that mentality
otherwise i would have been either
scared off or said hey that's not for me
so you have to be able to say i'm ready
to cross that line
you know in order to make some money
have power get the prestige
it has to be in you you know and you
know it's funny when i got when i got
made
um there was an expression prior to the
70s where
the books had been closed since the
1950s meaning they weren't
bringing any new guys into the family
unless somebody had died or passed away
then their families were allowed to
bring in somebody else
so for a lot of years for a security
measure they didn't they didn't you know
up the ranks
in the early 70s mid 70s they started to
open the books and make people again so
when i got made at the age of 24
those were guys were waiting 20 years
they were old-timers they were waiting
so they would you know just around doing
what they had to do they were
recruits for 20 years and these people
were street guys you know
they did a lot of stuff on the street
and uh
but again i guess you know that's a long
answer to you you have to be willing to
cross the line you have to have
something in you
that life has to be attractive to you
and quite honestly you know if your kid
growing up in brooklyn
and you're looking at these guys it is
attractive
i mean they drive the right cars they
get the best table at a restaurant
you know people respect them they fear
them in a way
and they dress well so you know it's a
lifestyle that looks very attractive
interesting yeah uh sunil do you think
there's a type of person that ends up
becoming a cop because i know from my i
had a lot of experience in hospitals
which is not
i wouldn't recommend but i found that a
lot
of the hospital staff not all doctors
and not all nurses and everything but a
lot of the people who end up working
there
are in there because they want some sort
of power over somebody else
um and it's not and then there are the
people in there that want to help people
yes
so do you think um there's a type of
person that ends up becoming a cop
well for me uh it's almost like when
michael was talking about right now
it's almost seemed like other than
crossing the line and other than some of
the other things some of the reasons
why uh i know a lot of my friends
and when i did it uh it was mainly
um you know for the fact that
um somebody came to me my uncle came to
me and said you should
do this and and i said yes and then from
that age
i lived in a parkdale it's an area in
toronto in the 80s
which was really we were in new
immigrants there was not much
of yeah it was quite cheap to live there
and all that stuff so
we lived in a not so great area and
and and we saw the gangs we saw the
prostitution we saw
some of the stuff that was going on the
van would show up with the drugs and all
that
and and and people would hurt people and
all that kind of stuff
so my thing was when i was growing up
was every time i looked at that i said
when i become a police officer this is
all going to be cleaned up i was pretty
naive at that time i was like
i'm going to clean up clean up all the
streets i knew the back alleys
i knew which which what was happening
where i knew people i knew
somebody i even knew in schools because
that's what the role i took it
at the 17 18 19 year old i knew who was
caring what kind of weapon
in schools and what they were doing and
my agenda was very simple
is when i become a police officer this
is all going to be cleaned up
and that's all i dreamed that's when i
went to sleep that's when i went for
exercise when i did right
when i ran um you know for hours on on
the local streets because we were pretty
poor and and so for me
um uh one thing is that uh there are
there people are there officers and are
they
that that have power trip of course they
there are like that but those are uh
exaggerated a lot because out of 100
people two of them do it we only want to
talk to those two people not the 98
people who are
and so then i also went into recruiting
i went into the crime unit where i
actually did background
searches and all checks on other people
and so when you look at the people who
are applying to the police force none of
them really apply and says i'm gonna
have a power trip
i'm gonna be done most of them high
majority of them
was was they they actually genuinely
wanna do well for their uh for their
country they wanna they wanna help
people they wanna do all that stuff
now over the years sometimes when they
realize that they don't really have that
power like i was naive
to think that when i become a police
officer i'm gonna go and change the
world
and change everything but what i realize
is my boss is going to say you're not
going to work here you're going to work
over there
and i can't say well i want to work it
is it's simple as that
and and so for me
my world in toronto was very simple um
we live in the same area we we want to
be police officers we want
we want to help out and we want to do
well for the world and we want to
we want to be able to serve the public
that's really
my world and the world of you know
people
eating lots of donuts or or people who
are
mean or a lot of stuff there were some
small percentage of those but they all
got the the floor basically
i wanted a evil cop story yeah you did i
know
i know it's not as cool i cannot compete
with michael he's got a better story
than i do but
but it's got a stressful story yeah it
does i mean but we
but a lot of stuff that he talks about
the brotherhood uh you know hanging
around the right people
hanging out with these similar people
even in the bad areas and all that stuff
i i saw the bad side of the society but
somebody a mentor came to me
like for michael he did it for his
father to get out for me it was my uncle
who says look
you should be a police officer and
you're going to do well and if he hadn't
said that
if he hadn't come to my home and said
that that day
i wouldn't have but from that day on day
and night i was dreaming i was
visualizing
i was affirming i was seeing myself as a
police officer
even at the age of 15 16 17 and all that
kind of stuff
because everything to me was all about
that's what i want to do with my life
have you from from what you learned in
business
um michael this is for you what
let me see how do i phrase this
what kind of lessons did you take away
from doing what you did
that taught you anything about human
behavior that you still
use now like did you learn about what
people were like in a certain way
because you must have been in incredibly
like i said stressful
situations so did you learn do you have
any lessons you took away that probably
positively impacted you there i've
changed my question
well yeah i mean you know many you know
when you talk about stress
it's funny you know the doctor asked me
do you have stress
and i said well i don't know how i need
that
i have stress i'm not in the mafia
i i don't even know it's you know this
is my life so i'm just used to dealing
with stuff so
that's cool yes i don't know you know so
i but it probably is i'm just saying i
can't even
decline it in my own life but but um
yeah there was there was so many things
i learned you know
in that life when you're as active as i
was
you know involved in a lot of different
things i was always in negotiations with
other guys i always had to sit down over
some of my men that were under me
you know and and work out some very
serious situations at times
so you really you really have to
understand
you know the mentality of the person
that you're across the table from
you know and a couple of great things my
dad taught me that that
stayed with me that helped me you know
certainly back then
and and in my life now is to always be a
good listener
never shoot off your mouth you know sit
down let the other person talk you know
glean
information before you respond it was
very important in that life because the
the ones that were very boastful and
talked all the time they didn't last
you know they they would fall into a
trap they'd make a mistake they'd say
something that would hang themselves
so i learned to be a good listener you
know not to shoot off my mouth quick
are honestly learn to respect people
give them respect you know
don't disrespect in that life you must
be respectful
if you're disrespectful to people it uh
it could be dangerous
you know suffer consequences so you know
that and then as far as the business
world well yeah i learned a lot of
things i mean i actually wrote a book
you know i'll make an offer you can't
refuse
and it was you know the way i used to do
business back then
the very machiavellian ideology that we
had
at that point in time the end justifies
the means do whatever you need to do to
succeed
always appear to be upright and honest
and have integrity
but underneath you can do whatever you
need to do as long as people view you in
the right way
you know and then i became you know
really fascinated with the book of
proverbs
and the teachings of solomon who really
teaches you the right way to live
you know forget the faith part just the
right way to live i mean you're just
just a brilliant person so you know a
lot of things from that life i took that
that have really served me well now you
know
now i mean i i've been a uh you know a
mentor and a life skills coach and a
business coach to many
and i have a community of almost 13 000
people that
we work with and we encourage we have
them encouraging one another
uh so it's it served me you know to work
in that capacity with people and you
know all the experience i have has
has been beneficial i think and i enjoy
it i mean
you know for me that's what it's all
about i mean you know they say in life
to those who have been given much much
is expected in return
and i've certainly be given a lot more
than i deserve so
we try to give back my dad's
very inspired by the book of proverbs
so that's that's cool to hear well your
dad's uh you know he's
he's certainly done very well for
himself and uh you know a lot of people
talk about him in a good way so
i'm glad to hear that yeah that's
because i tell you
and i tell people all the time it
doesn't matter what faith you are
you know the teachings of proverbs are
just so brilliant
you know when i was locked up i was in
the hole for uh 29 months and seven days
i was in solitary
holy and it was [ __ ] yeah 24 7
you know that was it you know just me
and god in that cell and
and obviously i read my bible many many
times but the book of proverbs
i i became a student of that book and
there's so many things that solomon
taught that apply to
our lives that is so beneficial whether
it be
you know personal or business because i
always tell people in business you're
going to run your business
pretty much the way you run your life
your life is disorganized and in a
shambles your business is not going to
be much better
and so get your life in order first and
then that will transfer to the way you
operate in business
and solomon teaches you a solid way how
to do both just how to live
you're a better salesman for that than
my dad is
well i don't know about that but
i'd love to talk to dad one day about
that since we have a similar interest in
that
sunil what did you learn because you're
in real estate now so what did you take
away from
your years um being a police officer
well as a police officer i mean there's
i i feel
all the skills are transferable whatever
you do whatever i did in policing
so so the negotiating i mean if you
can't negotiate a good deal
real estate let's say or any other deal
then you have no business so
that was very important for me
negotiation and
the other skills are just getting to
know and communicate with people
that are very important at the end of
the day for me negotiation wasn't about
i'm going to win and you're going to
lose negotiation was how do we
convey it in a way that we both win and
we actually both of us
will win the idea in the past was one
has to lose the other one has to win and
no i mean
that's that was very important if
somebody wants to jump off a bridge
and i each i would show up i mean you
know they're trying to kill themselves
i had to negotiate to say look don't
jump and
and something like that so that was very
important and um
what one of the skills was very
important that i learned
um is that that the failing was part of
it
meaning you can't be right all the time
so as a police officer i had to make a
decision
you show up and you make a decision and
not everything gets taught in college
police college
and all that kind of stuff because you
can't so you show up
and you have to make a decision so the
ability to take action
when you're not ready ability to take
action when you're not ready
has become really valuable for me
because anything that i do big
i'm not ready if i'm if i'm going to the
next arena
if i'm used to dealing with a million
dollar
deals and now i got 10 million dollars
dale i can see a lot of people will say
and they're more educated than i am they
they've been in real estate business
longer than i
have the first thing they all say is
that you know i'll think about it i'll
do it some other day or
i can't afford it and all that kind of
stuff but for me i would just go in and
go okay let's do it
and and then somebody will say well how
i said well i don't know we're going to
find a way to do it or we're going to do
it
so the ability to take action when
you're nervous you're scared
you know you think you can't do it or
you're going to the next level and every
time you explode to the next level
there's going to be
a a a door that you have to go through
that is that's going to say don't do it
be scared and it's not good so so so for
me to
take action massive action
when most people would go whoa slow down
don't do this and all that kind of stuff
uh that was a big big skill that i had
to
that i brought into the world of doing
so the ability to take action
was definitely important to me is that
just like
kind of be brave be brave and and and
just
do it biggest thing is that a lot of
times you know whether it was a
police officer or with a platoon
commander whatever when i show up at the
scene for example a lot of times
and when i was a boss i would show up
and there'd be like cruisers and there'd
be other people
witnesses people are and then whatever
scene and we need to bring choppers
so i show up and the first thing people
did was they all ran to me and said
this is the situation that's what's
happening what should we do what do we
do
and there are times where like damn i've
never come across this
but i can't say to those people you know
what
let me just drive away talk to my wife
about it or my brother or sister or
whatever
let me think about it and i'll come back
and give you direction no i couldn't do
that i had to do it
on the spot in the world of business i
get people a lot of them say
i i want to do just exactly what you do
i want to i want to become a
multi-millionaire
in a real estate and all that stuff said
great here's an opportunity
i was like yeah well that is pretty
scary i don't know i know i know so i
said how long have you been doing that
until some people have been doing for
all their lives and they're waiting for
the someday to come by or i'll do it
tomorrow i'll do it some other day
and so for me the
the the i recognize and realize that if
you're going to
you're at this step and you want to take
one more step maybe it's not that scary
okay but for me if i'm taking 10 steps
because that's really is going to change
my life making 200
positive cash flow from a property it's
not going to change a lot of
my life for much but going from 100
000 a year to a hundred thousand dollars
a month well that's a big step
you know you know so in that case
it's not going to happen while i'm
comfortable i feel great and
all the t's are crossed and all the eyes
are dotted so
the ability to take action when you're
scared
is a very important skill okay
michael you mentioned negotiating and
you mentioned
staying quiet but is there anything else
any other tips you can give us on what
you've learned from negotiation my
like my idea of mafia negotiating would
be
like that it wouldn't be much of a
negotiation
so so what was your experience there
well actually you know there is a lot in
it in the negotiation because what we
used to call them with sit-downs and i'm
sure you've heard of that yeah
everything was decided and resolved at a
sit-down whether it be something very
serious could have been somebody's life
at stake
could be a big business deal no matter
what it could have been something where
are we going to eat tonight you know
everything was in a sit down but you
know and there were certain
rules in a sit down for instance you
know if two maid guys guys that took the
oath were opposing one another on a deal
and i knew one of them was lying through
their teeth i couldn't call him a liar
if i call him a liar it's disrespectful
i lose the argument
there were certain things that you
couldn't do and the old-timers were very
very cagey they tried to you know bring
you into a trap where
they get you into a sequence of of
dialogue that would cause you to say the
wrong thing
and automatically lose the argument so
you had to be very sharp i mean look i
negotiated with john gotti and
castellano and all these guys
because when i was in the gas business
and we were making you know a tremendous
amount of money everybody tried to get
involved
so i was constantly sitting down and one
of the things i learned you know
again it goes back to letting people
talk there are times when you can be in
the room and i've learned that in the
negotiation now
you can be in the room and you can be
the smartest person in the room you
don't want anybody to know that
let them talk let them say everything
they got to say and at the end you got
everything that
you you need to know about them and then
you go on say what you need to say and
walk away a winner
there are other times when you're not
the smartest person in the room
well you don't want anybody to know that
either and when you're silent people
don't know what you're thinking
i don't know how smart this guy let him
talk let him talk let him talk
and i've found that to be so helpful in
any negotiation that i've ever had
also you also have to know the the uh
the person that you're dealing with do
your research
you know for instance when i sat down
with john gotti i knew that he was
uh and i'm not saying this you know to
be offensive to john
socially we got along well business-wise
he was very difficult to deal with
because he couldn't lose he was a
narcissistic type of guy he could never
walk out of thinking that he lost
so if you're in a situation with john
gotti you got to
you got to know what you're going to get
going in know what you'll settle for
and no matter what make him think he
want let him go out of there happy
but knowing that you got what you wanted
and i've had that situation with him so
you know knowing the person that you're
dealing with very important you know
whenever i negotiate business-wise i
kind of know the person that i'm dealing
with i know what he
you know his personality i know a little
bit about his company i get as much as
information
as i possibly can and then i know what
i'll settle for and you know
you got to be able in the negotiation to
walk away if things aren't right no
matter how
important a deal is for you you got to
be able to say you know what this is not
it
get up walk away and uh and move on to
the next thing or wait until the next
opportunity comes
so um i learned that because again in
that life i was very active
because of the you know the businesses
that i was in
and um i learned a lot with respect to
negotiation at that point and i have to
say i don't i don't
even with the federal government i
negotiated with the government and
one of the reasons i got violated is
because people said i pulled the wool
over the government's eyes that i beat
him in a way that nobody else ever beat
him
and there were reasons for that i i had
leverage over the government and it's
very important when you're in a guy
in my position to have leverage over the
government
and i was able to gain that leverage in
my negotiation and as a result
i walked away with a life where so many
people didn't didn't walk out that way
so
um again you know get as much
information as you can going in
know what you want know what you'll
settle for be able to walk away when you
have to
um and i think those are the most
important things in a negotiation
okay i might not be allowed to ask this
and so you can always just say no
obviously but what does leverage over
the government look like
well i'll tell you i'll make it brief
but
you know it was a strange thing when
rudy juliana indicted me on a huge
racketeering case i was a lead defender
i had 15 co-defendants
in the courtroom on the day of my
arraignment when i was getting bail
uh rudy came up to me and he said if i
convict you on this case you're going to
get double what your father got my
father got
50 years so he's going to give me a
hundred and that's the kind of time they
were given mob guys back then in the 80s
so that's the kind of time i was facing
i was on trial for several months
and what happened was my partner in the
gasoline business
had turned informant but he was
the witness for another case that they
were preparing against me in the eastern
district of new york
giuliani was a southern district of new
york so when giuliani heard
that a major informant um was ready to
testify against me cooperate against me
he wanted him as his witness now
i don't know how if you know i don't
know if it's the same in toronto but the
government always don't get along with
each other
so the eastern district and the southern
district are fighting over keeping this
witness
because they didn't want to give them up
to giuliani juliana had a lot of power
he goes to washington
he gets the witness the witness
testifies against me in that case
we destroy him on the witness stand and
i get acquitted in the case
so now the eastern district that was
preparing a huge case against me in the
gasoline business that
i really did have exposure on is
worried they're saying hey the main
witness just got destroyed he's not
worth anything anymore they were ready
to throw them out of the witness
protection program
so when i saw that i told my lawyer hey
i have a chance to negotiate a deal here
they're worried that was their major
witness we just destroyed them
let's go in and let me make the best
possible deal i can
that was the leverage i had if that
doesn't occur
i don't ever get a deal they would have
taken me to trial and who knows if i got
convicted i would have got at least 25
30 40 years
so um you know by the grace of god i got
that leverage but when i saw the
opportunity
i said this is the best chance i'm going
to get to walk away with my life in this
case
because i had beat them so many times
they would have killed me if i got
convicted on that case
with the amount of time that they would
have given me so you know you seen you
have a shot you got that leverage take
advantage of it go in and do the best
thing you can
and that's how it worked for me and
believe it or not when i say i got 10
years people were congratulating me
michael don't even take your shoes off
10 years is nothing you know you'll do
five or six years you're out and
i ended up doing eight but i ended up
doing you know getting away with
a life so for me it was huge
i was hoping i was gonna learn some some
techniques for leverage for myself but
i don't think i can use that
unfortunately you're not in that
situation
somebody just fine um okay
police negotiator what lessons on
negotiation did you take away
it can be like just anything simple
things just on how to get along with
other people
or get what you want or yeah well
there was a part where um when police
officers
would arrest somebody and then and then
there was a squad where they would call
the detectives to come in where the
let's call
the the person who got arrested did not
want to say anything
and despite what we see on movies that
csi and the fingerprints and all that
stuff majority of the cases are really
solved
by bad guys saying i did it and this is
how i did it and all that kind of stuff
it's
it's it's the ability to get the person
to say tell us
after we told them not to tell us that
is good to know
you know um um
and so so um some of the things that we
did
uh with uh that would be you know it's
very very interesting so for example
example
psychologically when you're walking down
the hallway into the police station we
would put pictures
of prime minister the queen and all that
stuff and they would put a picture of me
slightly above the prime minister's
picture
and you like if i were to ask you did
you see the pictures
most likely you won't even remember that
consciously but they would
if somebody basically says i'm not
telling you i'm not going to tell you
and all that stuff
so then we you know there was ways that
we did that so we
would put a picture of it of of
well-known people and then they would
put a picture of me
because they knew that i was coming and
then it would be slightly higher
than the others from from from a
subconscious point of view so
subconsciously when they're walking
and not even looking at that it's
registering subconsciously
into their mind so when they show up and
by the time i show up
one of the techniques that i used was
very simple
anything that person has done it i would
come in and say so
so let's say if somebody had assaulted
his wife or they had um done a robbery
or whatever it is
so if they did a robbery and nobody got
killed i would say okay look
you know you know you killed two people
during the robbery
and um i'm here especially for that case
alone and a lot of times people will get
upset and say i
never killed anybody all i did was
rob the bank and all that kind of stuff
so what happened
was every place you go to like with my
kids
and i would say son how could you beat
up that guy
dad i never beat him all i did was
shoved him
okay meanwhile if i asked him the other
way he would go ah i didn't do nothing
so if i own a let's say a squash courts
right
and i own a gym and all that stuff and
squash is not bringing money
it's a bad deal and it's taking a lot of
real estate in my
gym and i want but i have some people
that pay me every month for squash
i would instead of and so i have four
squash courts so
i really want to have one squash court
or two maybe so instead of me going okay
everybody
we're going to close these two squash
courts the reverse is also true
which is everybody we're closing all
squash
courts and no longer will be able to out
there if you have any questions
please tell us and you let them fight
for it they fight for i
know i want to how did that and then at
the end you go okay
good okay you guys won here's what we're
gonna do we're gonna keep two squash
courts
and we're going to team the other two
away now they saw they won
so with the kids with the people that uh
they they wanted to come in
so if if the person beat up his wife i
would come in
of course there's other things i did to
warm them up build a report
got them what they wanted to do i knew
what kind of lunch they wanted because
the officers
will talk to them so we would bring the
type of lunch exact food
exact drink everything would come with
that and i would come in as a good guy
and i would come in
and and then i would just basically say
look
um it doesn't look like you're a bad guy
i mean
all you did was i mean you know you beat
her up and now she's dead and now you
know
you're here the guy's like no no she's
not dead man i only punched her
oh okay before he says i'm not caught
talking to you
right and i said really you just punched
her so did she deserve it
and because she probably did deserve it
right
and he goes yes she absolutely tell me a
little bit more about that
and now they're they're opening up and i
shut up
they talk and everything is recorded and
and they're excited and you know what
they feel good about it
because they like no no i'm not that bad
like if i found somebody who
killed somebody one murder i would say
oh you killed five people they're like
no no i didn't kill five people
there's only one guy you know so she
always uplifted or
downsized it to to be able to get them
that was one of the
negotiation techniques that uh i
perfected
wow that's interesting that is
interesting yes
that seems that seems i mean you're
you're out there catching criminals so
you're being sneaky but that's
definitely sneakier than the
sit down seems sneakier than the
sit-downs that michael was talking about
which is just like don't is it called an
ad hominem attack
like no ad hominem attacks or you just
lose who decides if you lose in
negotiation at these sit downs
are they just like you called him you
got angry and called called him
something
bad and now this other guy wins like
what's that about yeah if the boss is um
officiating over this you know it it all
depends on what level you're on
for instance if two soldiers in the
family are
are having a disagreement and a sit-down
then their cop regimes their captains
could be the ones deciding this
but if it goes higher than that like i
was a captain
so if the boss was officiating over this
then he would make the final decision
and that's it whatever he decides that's
it win lose a draw you keep your mouth
shut you shake hands you walk away and
that's it
there's no appeals there's no second
chances you abide by it and
and that's it so he's the he's the final
say he's the judge the jury and
everything else
well my negotiation was in this case
with
people who are arresting what the sit
down that we would have would be with
our officers and our commanders and we
obviously wouldn't be using
this techniques with them so yeah it's a
different uh
scenario from that so when we have our
own meetings we would have
obviously somebody making a decision at
the end of the day
if two officers are not getting along
it's a similar thing as what you would
do
we just call it a meeting or staff
meeting and all that kind of stuff
okay so you guys are both like you've
got
a massive following on youtube um
you guys are both fairly well known
um i'll start off let's start off with
sunil
um what has that been like that have you
had how
how has that gone for you have you faced
any major challenges
yeah so um 2005 i've left the police
force and 2005 to 2008
is we did really well in 2008 comes
along the united states obviously
crashes the whole world really does but
the united states takes the
the worst it was the worst crash since
the depression
and uh we lost everything and um
and as i became let's call it famous
uh what happened was the media and
everybody else got involved so when
when i lost all the money my friends
lost the money some of the members lost
money
uh at the end of the day it was all
about who should we
point fingers to and what happened was
people
said okay so let's say there was a there
was an opportunity was a deal
where the developer from markham ontario
is selling hotel condos
we sell the hotel condos we buy some we
sell it to our members and all that kind
of stuff
and it's in 2007 and they got the
financing from
the u.s company and all that and so what
happens is market crashes
the entire you know everything gets melt
down so the developer does not get the
financing
so uh basically the the project that was
being built
in carousel which is an island uh which
is the which is what we bought into
developer just disappears from markham
he was the
oriental gentleman canadian oriental
gentleman who ended up going to china
and
disappearing as as a builder well they
said well who's the next person that we
can blame
and it was me and my company and all
that kind of stuff so they
they came after and they did all this
couple of years of investigation and all
that kind of stuff
and and they first thought that we took
the money what they
realized is we took the money i mean it
was with a developer
and it was a long securities
investigation
and at the end of the day basically it
came down to this
the paperwork that we did the promissory
notes that we did
and the agreements that we did because
somebody had because people had lost
money we lost money and all that kind of
stuff
um they said uh if you plead
you know guilty to this uh uh
provincially
um we'll let you leave leave you alone
and and they were after
for many many years and and there's a
case when
uh somebody hired me to speak one of my
students in winnipeg
and and then there's a bad article that
shows up that
and they say the headline says
man named in ponzi scheme doesn't say
that i was in ponzi it just says he's
named in ponzi's game
and then they started talking about
other stuff and then just said that
you know security commission
investigated me and all that kind of
stuff
so that was huge challenge as i if i
wasn't as
if i hadn't grown the way i did and if
um
all i could i'm pretty sure uh at the
end of the day
basically uh i was told that okay you
know what we need
uh people have lost money we need to
find some we need to do something about
it at the end of the day it came down to
just that
the piece of paper that we used could be
seen as a security in real estate
and that's what happened big challenge
that was a big challenge to come through
i mean
even today people do that even after we
have helped hundreds and hundreds of
people
and have a lot of people become wealthy
in real estate
still some people will look at that and
yet we will have hundreds of
hundreds of people saying cinel changed
my life and that shows up
and that's the challenge that i faced
media what's that the media
yes they're lovely media like you you're
a lovely media all right oh i see okay
that's different though
we don't have to get into the other
media um michael
have you had any challenges that you've
faced since becoming more of a public
figure
well you know i've been out there for
for a lot of years now um
you know and i have to say for the most
part it's been very positive for me
obviously i have a past unlike sunil
that you know people can
you know always bring up you know and i
hear it you know you were a mobster you
were this you were that you were this
and especially since you know my
presence on youtube has
has really grown in the past several
months i mean we only started
in july and we're approaching a half
million
subscribers and um you know it's it's
been very very fortunate
that we have uh that kind of a following
but you know
i would say look when you're a public
figure you know when you have a
background like i have
you you take the good with the bad you
know that some people are gonna come at
you
i would say you know maybe one percent
out of a hundred percent uh i get
negative
stuff on but it's it's people on the
internet you know
i i i will say this and i hope people
don't take this wrong but
you know social media has exposed some
of the lunacy in the world i have to say
that there's people
that say things that i don't even know
what they're talking about they don't
even
they don't even comment properly on the
things that were stated in the in the
video i mean it's crazy i'm sure
miguel you might experience stuff like
that but uh you know for the most part i
have to be honest
you know the worst thing that's happened
to me is some people trying to play off
of my success
you know using my name to get views of
their own
you know people that you don't even know
really that are just starting to talk
about you whether it be
positive negative and they're trying to
get views you know and i get that look
everybody's got to make a living they
all try to do what they do but you know
i have to say for the most part people
have been very wonderful
um you know i've gotten so many friends
and so many good relationships over the
years
uh remember i've been speaking i speak
like 40
other than through covid i'm you know
i'm on the road 40 weeks out of the year
all over the world speaking in various
places
always received well people have been
very kind very generous so
i i really have nothing to complain
about i mean i've been uh extremely
fortunate
in in this new career that i've had over
the past 20 some odd years
do you have time for one more question
then we can let you go sure
what was what was
is there any part of that kind of life
that you miss
well yeah i mean i get asked that a lot
and listen
you know it is um it's an exhilarating
life at times look
i i think there's nothing more powerful
among men than this brotherhood
you know i got your back you got mine i
mean there are certain perks that when
you
elevate yourself your position in that
life you know it's nice
i mean look i had a jet plane i had my
own helicopter
i had a house in florida house of new
york house in marina del rey california
i had 300 guys under me ready to do
anything i tell them to do
i'm making you know a couple of million
bucks a week i mean those are the
figures
it's it's all out there it's public
record um
and with that comes a certain amount of
prestige and enjoyment and and
everything else so
you know there were times when i missed
that i would never go back to it
i'm very content and happy and thrilled
with the life that i have right now
but uh you know most mostly i miss the
guys
i miss the brotherhood the camaraderie
that we had
and as a matter of fact you know sad to
say one of my guys i called him frankie
gangster frankie g because he was very
loyal and all he ever wanted to be was a
gangster and
you know he was like the joe pesci of of
reality of real life
and he just passed away two days ago
from covet you know and and i was very
sad he was kind of like
the last of my crew to go and i'm i'm
the survivor my dad passed away
last year at the age of 103 right so
you know everybody is is gone so yeah i
mean
you know look i'd be lying if i didn't
say that there were times in there when
i i really enjoyed being a part of that
life
but i also want to do this i have to say
this
and it's important because i don't want
to give people the impression that i'm
glorifying the life i don't
i say all the time i call that life an
evil life michaela and i call it evil
not because the men are evil i was one
of them you know i just happen to be
very fortunate
but i have not seen one
family of any member of that life
including my own
not my wife and kids but my you know
father mother brothers and sisters
that haven't been totally devastated
devastated
and any lifestyle that does that to a
family is a bad life
and that's what i tell these gang
bangers you're going to destroy your
family if you have one and if you don't
when you do get one stay in this life
you're going to destroy them
i've seen it you know i had a mother 33
years without a husband
when she died at the end of her life the
relationship between my dad and her was
ugly because she blamed him for
everything that went wrong
what went wrong well i had a sister that
died at the age of 27
odd on drugs my brother was a drug
addict 25 years
had more problems than you can imagine
my younger sister died of cancer at the
age of 41 or 42
and that was it and and every member i
know
their families suffer similar fates so
you know how could you glorify a
lifestyle that does that to people
and i want to make that clear because i
don't even want you know viewers to
think that i'm glorifying the life
but i have to admit that there were
times that i enjoyed it i mean
you know i'm just being honest but i'm
glad i'm out i'm very blessed to be
where i am today i have no
uh you know no regrets about the way my
life just turned out
and and that's it
okay so same same question
same question to you well the
interesting part is almost
everything that michael says really um
opposite world
except for i didn't have the helicopters
and i didn't have the
private jets and all that stuff the
brotherhood really the friendships
they were just unbelievable and
the the ability to call somebody at any
time basically
and ask or need help or or just to say
hello
or or just being able to trust that
person is just unbelievable
and not only that person but the entire
brotherhood
is is is huge and and the relationships
are deeper
um at least i felt that and uh first
time in my life i had
very few friends when i was growing up
and growing into the policing
i had probably the most of my good
friends were in the police force
and and then what i miss is that most of
the most of those officers
when i became wealthy uh don't really
associate with that because again they
are they they love what they do and i
don't blame them because i loved what i
did
as well so being able to um
do that job itself was some component
with that was
was so much fun it was amazing i i i i
respect police officers and i respect
what they have good
they have to go through in today's world
especially when everybody has to you
know they got cameras they have to put
cameras on and all that kind of stuff
you say a word one word differently
it could be taken differently and all
that kind of stuff yeah
and some of it is awesome because you
know we have cameras and all that stuff
but on the other hand um i really
respect the officers
more so today because it's not easy job
it's absolutely not
easy whatsoever it doesn't matter what
level what
division what station that you work it
it's not
uh when i started in 1990 is definitely
different
than today because i know some of my
good friends
right now who are officers and they're
good people they're good
amazing human beings i've been on for 20
years 25 years or whatever
and i miss the idea
of protecting and serving people
in that manner
[Music]
i pro i i wouldn't go back to it
uh some of it was long hours rotating
shifts
family issues meaning you know um you
know a lot of officers don't have
at the end of the day and a lot of
officers are
divorced several times men and women
in that profession and um that
was uh interesting aspect of that life
but it definitely was some it's
definitely something that
if somebody from my family says i want
to be a police officer or
or mike i i help them actually a lot of
officers to become officers if
if that's what they want to do it's a
it's a noble profession
okay michelle if i can add to that i
just
want to make something clear too you
know people think that because of my
background that i'm anti-law enforcement
and there's i couldn't be further from
the truth many friends that i've made
over the years
are law enforcement one of my dearest
friends is a chief of police
over at ucla college he was with the
beverly hills police department
i've made those relationships throughout
the country and
you know i tell people all the time why
would i be anti-police
i have daughters i have a wife when they
walk down the streets
i want them protected and i know law
enforcement is going to do that
so you know where i had this distorted
sense of view growing up with law
enforcement fortunately
you know my mind has been transformed
and and i realized the value of law
enforcement i think what's going on in
america is terrible
defund the police and all this
ridiculous notions that are going on
we need the police we need law
enforcement you know obviously there's
always uh
you know things that you can do to
improve any walk of life so that's true
of the police also
but we need to police the department uh
i'm very very supportive
of of our law enforcement and you know
we had a saying
in our life which i think sunil you'll
you'll appreciate
we understood law enforcement had their
job to do
and we did our job we knew we were on
different sides
you do your job you catch us the right
way hey we don't disrespect you for that
all we ever said was don't frame us
don't make up charges you got all the
tools and all the weapons on your side
come and get us the right way we have no
complaint
and uh and that's how we felt and as
many you know we didn't abuse
law enforcement we didn't we did none of
that you know we understood their role
and what our role was
and today even more so i respect the job
that they do have a rough job you know
in some of these cities man
and you know i saw it in prison i saw
what some of these guards had to go
through
because of some of the inmates that come
in and were so disrespectful and
and just just didn't act right you know
and you know that's not the way to live
your life you know you got to respect
people no matter
who they are if they're giving you
respect you give it back and and that's
just the way it goes so i just wanted to
say that to you sunil so that you thank
you mike thank you michael
i appreciate that yes yes
okay michael where can people find you
online
well um you might my website is just my
name michaelfrances.com
and um you know i i really encourage
people to take a look and you know maybe
join our community it's free to get in
there people are encouraging one another
it's been a great resource especially
through the pandemic
and it's growing you know every day i'm
on youtube
i'm on facebook i'm on twitter i'm on
instagram i don't even know what my
handles are just throw my name in there
and you'll find me
and um you know that's it so uh you know
i appreciate you having me
uh it was a great interview and you know
just let me know
if i can too i'll i'll post it on all my
uh my sites and
uh let people see it okay i'll shoot you
over when it's done it's neil where can
people find you
uh private
privateinvestmentclub.comprivateinvestmentclub.com
i have some videos on youtube just
punching my name sneltolceni
and uh it's it's mainly for people who
want
to uh become wealthy in real estate and
and that's my main focus
is to help people uh invest in real
estate especially in 2021 and beyond
that's that's what i that's if
somebody's interested in real estate
investing
that's where they go private investment
club.com great well i will link
everything below so people can check out
check it out there but thank you very
much that was fun
you